one thing that you want to see want us
to get you see you sure we got right
there if you want it you uh you see John
way walking up along with a little
bounce in his step and he had that big
behind huge behind the brothers on the
team chocolate chocolate chip anything
you want to talk about Joe anything you
want to talk you got it slides we're
good to go
what are we going live on and IG right
there and are you live or not yet any
second yeah and you're good
do I need to touch this at all you're in
great shape
311 everybody it's gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is a sewed 311 of the askgaryvee
show
and one that i will watch in perpetuity
forever easily one of the most important
men of my life without him fully knowing
it to this every single code that i ever
had on my ATM my passwords several years
ago when i started realizing more people
knew who i was i had to go and change
everything from January 12th 1969
because I felt that people would
eventually figure out that those were
all my passwords it's Joe it's real real
honor to have you here obviously my fan
base knows literally what you probably
don't know is I immigrated to this
country from the Soviet Union originally
lived in Queens and then moved to Edison
New Jersey and the real way I got
Americanized was was absolutely New York
Jets football my first season back to
John Riggins we were talking before we
started this was the 82 season which was
a great one for the Jets and you know
obviously had they be in Miami they
would have played John Riggins skins
that game and literally from that day on
it has become the core the core thing in
my life is the New York Jets besides my
family so you can imagine how much fun
it is to have you here so thanks for
being on well thank you thanks for
having me so I have a lot of things I
want to talk to you about and the format
of shows we do calls obviously I've been
promoting on social so a bunch of people
are gonna be super excited to call in
I'm gonna start with a couple of
different things I think you know the
one luxury of actually being a hardcore
Jets fan and is that I think I can take
these in different directions than the
normal stuff so actually what I want to
talk about is the season after the Super
Bowl a game that kind of still sits
obviously this happened I was born in 75
but the game against the Chiefs that we
lost in the playoffs the next year I
guess my first question would be was the
team after the Super Bowl a better team
than a Super Bowl team and obviously
better is a funny word but did you think
we were gonna win Super Bowl four I
didn't necessarily think we were gonna
win Super Bowl four but we felt like we
were playing well and we ended up
playing a team that outplayed us that
day the Kansas City Chiefs man and you
bring it up yeah yeah it was a windy
cold funky day and insane yeah if we
were home and we got held to six points
all right I'm aware Bobby Bell they had
more even four or five defensive players
in the Hall of Fame now yeah I mean that
they were good and I remember play that
I actually thought about trying to fool
Bobby Bell during the week when we're
getting ready and I made a big mistake
you don't fool Bobby Bell you know a
great linebacker that he was and we only
scored six points they beat us man what
do you when I bring up that game right
what what are the what are the biggest
things that you think about like did you
did that game stick with you because
obviously I mean and some of this stuff
I might get wrong because obviously I
wasn't around but the next season you
got hurt right because the next season
was a four and eleventh season right and
it was like how much I don't I don't
know you well enough to know you know is
it stuff you think about is it not but
that season for some reason I don't know
why it sticks obviously everybody talks
about the prior season
but there's you know and lend awesome
you know what kind of player was Lynn
Dawson Lenny does and was sweet man I
mean he was sweet he was smooth I tried
to run like with his mannerisms his
coolness he was a real gentleman and he
was brilliant as a player but that game
that season like this did that hurt for
a long time or were you you had so much
going on in your life at that point
obviously the prior season puts you on a
pedestal in this city the biggest city
in the world are you the kind of guy
that after that game you're devastated
for 24 hours you think about it for a
month or you go down to Miami and have
fun like what kind of guy were you like
I'm very curious what happens after that
level of adversity I assume we're at
home you're pretty you know the readers
were really good team that year too so
you have to face those guys again if you
win but like what are you upset or you
kind of like you understood that they
outplayed you like how did your psyche
I'm trying to get into the mindset of
you're walking off the field and then
what happens the next 30 days Gary I'll
share with you what my head coach told
my freshman class of football players at
the University of Alabama the first time
we met our head coach and had a meeting
with him coach Paul Bear Bryant he stood
up in front of us and he said I'm gonna
teach y'all how to keep from beating
yourselves now I came from PA me and Ike
it's tough for me to understand him and
we want a championship back there and
Beaver Falls and that sounded to me like
what plan conservative or playing feared
I'm gonna teach you all how to keep from
beating yourselves and then he said
you're gonna remember the losses the
mistakes the games you didn't play well
in more than you're going to remember
the good games even the big games you
have won to this day you bring up the
Kansas City Chiefs game in 1969 I
promise you that's one of the ones we're
talking about coming Shoji Bryant losing
the Texas by senior year in the Orange
Bowl that jumps up at me losing once to
that
team from across the Alabama state a
burn archive for most folks but even
losing to them that gets me right here
to this day sure we won the championship
man and I mention high school cause the
goal for every player should be to make
the team own up you got to be good
enough to get on any team whether it's
Little League baseball junior high
basketball you got to make the team and
the next goal should be to win the
championships right and we did it on
those levels and I'm thrilled about that
but I think of the games I played like a
bum first do you think you played like a
bum in that game in which game the
Kansas City Chiefs game I know there's
four picks in that oh well but you know
real football fans know some of those
are on the quarterback and some of our
or not and some are on a good defensive
play you know but no I mean I didn't
play well had I played well we would
have possibly won again you know what
net that triggers a thought we think
about Tom Brady I think about Tom Brady
in this day and age and after watching
him over the years I know I literally
lost the game or more when I played for
the Jets I haven't seen Tom Brady in 18
years or since he's been playing for the
Patriots cost them a game well you know
it's funny because the playoff game that
we went up there and beat them on I
thought the past that he threw that
Davis David Harris intercepted changed a
complete complexity of that game
throughout the rest of the game so I'll
chalk that up to Tom Brady's loss okay
that's one play that name is tough to to
deal with as you can imagine let me ask
you another question that I was really
curious about this is getting by the way
everybody was watching you put in calls
I'm gonna talk to I'm gonna talk to Joe
a lot about marketing because I think
what Sonny did and we'll get into this
with I'm very curious from your
perspective of being the human there is
no question in my mind and my brother AJ
and I started this marketing company and
several years ago he left to follow his
passion and my brother is
in the football sports representation
business so he's he's a football agent
obviously we come from marketing
background so you can imagine I'm very
affected with the way you became who you
were in the public eye and that wasn't
just who you were as a charismatic
successful player
it was the people around you that were
helping you make decisions on brand
deals the SI cover is all-time the
pantyhose thing is all-time there's a
lot of things that were done between you
and your team that has created the
legendary status that you are you know
obviously the game is so
disproportionately powerful but I don't
think people understand how a full thing
is usually built so I for everybody's
watching because I know marketing and
entrepreneurship such a big part of me
in this show we'll get to that you're
gonna have to stick with me because I'm
going very nerd football here because
I've got to see it through for myself
I'm very curious and I actually don't
have as much knowledge about this
because this is the period where I don't
know as much about Richard Todd this is
very interesting to me because the 82
season is my first season and he was the
Jets quarterback at that time so he was
my first Jets quarterback he you know
when I look at the history books and
read stuff he comes into the team with
all this Fame and things of that nature
there's a story I can't recall about
something with you you said some amazing
joke to him at like a training camp or
something I don't remember the whole
story and I might even be getting it
wrong I'm curious as a nerdy nerdy Jets
fan where were you at the point of your
career how did what was your
relationship like with him like tell me
like when I say that name give me a
story or two that maybe you haven't told
or like give me give me a scoop here Joe
tell me something about you and Richard
Todd every year that I played pro
football the 13 years that I played I
would go back to Tuscaloosa Alabama
began to Train that's right that's where
I do my training I'd go I apologize
everyone's laughing now because I'd love
to do it as a PA boy I mean you've
obviously I've seen you talk about a lot
coach coach down there and that seat
like you that was really
transformational for you that time down
there huh it was I I didn't even visit
the campus before I went there I didn't
know coach Paul Bear Bryant at the time
I saw Alabama play one game before I
went there and that was in the Liberty
Bowl and I'm black and white television
and and I really didn't know anything
about it okay who came in second for Joe
Namath second where if you didn't go to
Babbo where would have you gone Maryland
University of Maryland has asked the
College Board's but I didn't score high
enough on the college you are Ireland no
I didn't want to go to college I wanted
to play baseball I had the opportunity
to sign a baseball contract but at home
it was at a time that we still you know
did what your mother your father said
and my father and mother had divorced
her early on not so early but it was
early in my life and now it was time to
decide what the youngest and the family
was going to do go to college or sign
the baseball contract and so we had a
meeting at the house my oldest brother
ran the meeting my mother was sitting
there and brother Bob so well mom he
turned to he said mom what do you want
you to do and my mother said all I want
Joey to go to college Bob hit the table
that's it you go to college that was it
that was it and where you pissed I was
crushed
I couldn't be too angry because Bob
could still beat me up - you are
disappointed oh man I had a brand-new
starfire Pontiac convertible picked out
man powder blue with a chrome strip
along the side a white top $50,000 bonus
in 1961 which is looking pretty cool
yeah man you can't no wonder I loved the
baseball I'd run around and catch and
bat like Roberto Clemente there tried to
you know I really love baseball
but mom when do you go to college that
was that and you first wish and then
Maryland hit your radar because Marilyn
why I like Tom Nugent the coach there I
liked his style a football they threw it
a lot he started the i-formation when he
was at Florida State and and he was just
a charismatic guy so this was not an era
where a big prospect like Joe Namath
not passing the board's like Marilyn
couldn't figure out some funny like this
that wasn't the ecosystem in college
well that didn't work that way and what
happened is coach Nugent called coach
Bryant and let him know that I was still
loose interesting and unbeknownst to me
I didn't know Howard Schnellenberger an
assistant coach at Alabama at that time
showed up at our house and Beaver Falls
there's a knock at the door and he came
in and talked to my mother she went
upstairs packed me a suitcase you could
put under the front seat of this you
know was sick now on a plane it was that
big came downstairs gave me a $5 bill
and looked at coach Schnellenberger said
take him and that was it man I was off
to Tuscaloosa Alabama I never heard of
the loose Alabama before that what about
Alabama itself well I did see him play
in the Liberty Bowl I like their style
man I they had dark head gears and white
uniforms that day I remember and I
caught myself pulling for them but they
lost and so back to the story so you go
down and Todd is down there one of those
off seasons what you see I was again
already playing pro ball but I'd go back
to Train May June early June before our
training camp and Richard was the
quarterback at Alabama one of those
years and they were running a wishbone
offense when he was a senior but when he
was a younger player before they put the
wishbone and Richard was still running
sprint out stuff and throwing so I used
to work with Richard specifically on
dropping back the straight drop bang yes
he had a strong arm and he was good he
was a big hard good teammate man you'd
like everything about Richard except
that day gets Miami maybe down there in
the bad weather with AJ that's the first
time I cried only the 86 Browns loss
made me cry harder but that was a tough
one
yeah well there you know some are
tougher than others they all stink you
know you never get tired of winning
two things in life we don't get tired of
staying healthy and winning for sure you
know your girlfriend to run you off
you're gonna run her off sometimes so
did you tell the Jets they you thought
that like was there ever a conversation
between you in the front office about
time there might have been cuz we
drafted him number one yeah in 76 we
drafted Richard number one and Richard
had great training with Coach Bryant I
mean he was a fine player and strong but
how much pressure was on him in New York
because he came from Bama you know he
also had good hair his was blond like
like was there a lot of pressure and
expectation on him I would live on I
would think more than I could realize
not about that no no we didn't know man
we were buddies yeah I mean we were like
yeah I mean we hung out well you know we
were together man
and no I didn't ask him about the
pressure didn't want to make anything
about yeah you're gonna follow him I
wasn't that kind of thing Joe another
question back to nerdom what's the
biggest thing you lock let you learned
from when you went to LA look you know
obviously there was a difficult they did
like that for at least from what I can
see it wasn't a success it wasn't a
great success but no forget about what
happened on the football field per se or
maybe something you learned on the
football field I don't know if I asked
you what was the single biggest thing
you learned with the Rams you know
experience what was it to get something
positive out of a negative season which
happened to be the teammates that I did
play with Jack Youngblood Tom Mac you
know these kind of catch Laurence
mccutchins Jackson the friendships that
I developed with the players the coach
Chuck Knox there at the time Chuck was
our offensive line coach with the Jets
my rookie season and sex relationship
yeah but I couldn't play as well I had
to severed hamstrings in my left leg I
played my last five years or so with and
you can't run with
severed hamstring but you can still play
quarterback to some extent you do you
when you watch the current state of the
rules for quarterbacks in the NFL do
once in a while like I have you know
anybody you know it's kind of like the
classic thing that everybody does right
- like a son or a daughter like in my
day I walked in like there has to be
when these phantom 15-yard penalty 's
where the guy sneezes on the quarterback
meanwhile the Raiders are literally
double pile driving you to the concrete
in these games like at some level once
in a blue moon on a Sunday in the last
five years you've got to be like geez
what I could have done if this was the
rules when I played no never no good a
lot you don't allow yourself to do that
well I don't I was trained that way in a
sense coulda woulda shoulda excuse me
and no yeah but still forget about you
do you just laugh about like do you
laugh about no now I'm gonna tell you
sister I did color right I did with NBC
I made the statement I said I don't care
if Hulk Hogan is back there in the
pocket he's gonna get hurt they needed
to change the rules they needed because
if you knock the best guy out quality
the game's going downhill and the fans
are losing out yep they're not getting
the best possible performance you had to
protect the quarterbacks some because
hey the backups are backups for no
reason yeah and you keep going down man
it's the quality a game that suffers how
close did the the st. Louis drafted you
along with the Jets two separate leagues
how close were you not a jet I was
shocked at st. Louis actually have you
know what real for real yeah this is one
that I really want to know this is all
for real I promise you that
the st. Louis Cardinals showed up
unannounced in Tuscaloosa Alabama and my
dorms Lobby I'm up in my room doing what
I get I'm I'm up in my room
not a name it there's a couple of guys
to see you that I didn't even know who
drafted me it wasn't like today we
didn't know it wasn't televised it
wasn't phone call with you no I mean
these two guys came upstairs one was the
general manager and one was one of the
owners and they sat down on my bed cuz I
wouldn't let him sit on my roommates bed
my room with Pelham butch Henry was
named after general telemon southern you
know the Confederacy anyway we sat on
the bunks and won the owner guy told me
they had drafted me and and wanted
assign me to the contract and I said oh
well good but I haven't heard from the
other team it he said what that's all
right you know you're not gonna have to
listen to them we're gonna sign you and
we're gonna offer you well no it wasn't
we're gonna offer you they asked me what
I wanted to play and coach Bryant had
asked me that same question after the
Auburn game our last game of the regular
season and I told coach Bryant in the
locker room as I was down on my knee
putting a sock on our backup quarterback
Steve Sloan's leg because he was hurt
too and I said well coach Don truehl
sign for a hundred thousand last year I
saw I was thinking of 100 hundred
thousand I'm looking up a coach Bryant
coach Bryant took a draw off that big
old Chesterfield cigarette he is doing
Ernie blew some smoke I said well you go
ahead and ask him for two hundred
thousand that's a better place to start
these guys so what do you think you're
gonna want period I told him I could
hardly get it out you know two hundred
thousand dollars and the guy fell back
the owner fell back Oh hundred thousand
the other guy start are you crazy to
understand and I remembered oh and the
new car - oh you want to car - do you
you want a new car - yes sir you see
baseball / you know you got to get that
baseball car back yes B what kind of car
cuz I
I talked to old high school teammate
maybe a few days before and he asked me
what I was gonna ask for and I told him
about coach Bryant and asking me that
money
and he said well man what kind of short
you gonna get I said well I don't know I
didn't think about that he's all you
need to get your Lincoln Continental
he said it's got them barn doors those
doors that open out this way enough and
so I told the owner and general manager
I said hey a Lincoln Continental they
looked at each is oh sure yeah he was a
Lincoln God that made me feel like yeah
jerk and so how did it end did they well
they thank you know the man went in his
briefcase and pulled out a contract
pulled out a contract and he said no
look okay where do I
he's gonna you got this contract he's
gonna pass no don't go no wait a minute
we got a bowl game yet coach Bryan had
told myself and what other guys see that
we're seniors you know we had a bowl
game coming up January 1st so they tried
to get me to sign right then they knew
the rule course but you know that's okay
I just had to tell them no I can't do
that now we've got a game coming up
coach Bryan actually told us though if
we were being recruited don't you even
take a coke Cola from any of these guys
yeah that's right because we had a game
coming up and so you got him out of the
room somehow without side yeah that's
right and I sat there alone wondering
Wow you know what do I do now so I
called a buddy uh that there was a
student a regular student he was a
dealer in Las Vegas in between semesters
at QB and he came over picked me up with
drove down to a restaurant called the
deep south for a cup of coffee to talk
this over it's cool and it's he and I
had talked and I said down yeah I gotta
get some help so I got up and went to
the pay phone at the time it was a dime
for the pay phone and called a buddy up
in Alabama was a lawyer mr. Michael
Michael bite and told him the situation
and so then I had legal representation
and Mike handed
the rest of the way for that initial
contract and the Jets one
well the Jets one they flew me and Mike
actually might paid for the plane fare
to fly to Los Angeles and I met mr.
Werblin in Beverly Hills at the Beverly
Hills Hotel unbelievable and it was
spectacular and he wanted me to sign
with the Jetson that we were able to go
to a game and watch the Jets and the San
Diego Chargers play down in San Diego we
drove down there and then I went back to
Alabama and we met again with mr.
whirling and well he was the man doing
everything yes even though we
partnership but he was running it yeah
yes that's right and had we beYOU Bank
being a general manager knew something
about football you know the other owners
were in Thoroughbred industry the oil
industry the fashion industry they were
different and it just the kind of guy
mr. Werblin was was an influence and
that's the thing coach Bryant told me
get to know the people you're gonna work
for and that was so important because it
became a no contest you know after the
two guys how quickly did your
relationship with Sonny turn into him
saying like how thought did he
communicate to you that hey kid I'm
gonna make you a superstar like his
blueprint on treating you like he
treated other celebrities from LA was
not a model that was in sports up until
that point I mean that Broadway Joe
thing is real real real stuff that is
like I don't think people understand in
this day and age what Sports Illustrated
meant what that cover meant every single
young guy in the country sees that
magazine cover and that positions you
right away did you know that that was
going on or was he just kind of doing it
or was that something that you were a
part of yeah you right on you're right
on it was mr. Werblin at one point I
overheard him say telling someone else
whether it was
his wife and I together who else is it
stars sell tickets
he created the star system he should so
to speak in professional football show
we had Red Grange many years ago Jim
Brown was a star you know but babies
that were started to in a sense they
weren't built up we weren't build up and
you crossed over he embraced the media
in New York he started inviting the
media into areas and buying them lunch
and visiting with them he reached out to
the media and he he he got it off the
ground man I mean I don't it wouldn't
surprise me if he called Sports
Illustrated himself to get that picture
on Broadway yeah he was instrumental not
only in my career but the AFL's how did
it feel the first time you saw you
yourself on the cover of Sports
Illustrated like that I was stunned
first time I saw it we were practicing
at Shea I came in off the practice field
and on my stool and every other players
stool around the locker room was that
magazine a Sports Illustrated with my
smiling face looking up I had a few
veterans pick up the magazine look at it
and then throw it at me
young duck in magazines you know
embarrassed actually you know it was
kind of scary some of them are cursing a
little bit about it you know and I'm
sitting here straight across like where
he's sitting over there straight across
to me the offensive lineman her sitting
there and our offensive leader Sherman
Plunkett offensive tackle who was about
65 and we didn't know how much he
weighed because the scales only went up
to 300 and you see and I used to carry
Sherman's helmet off the practice field
from training camp to that day he would
give his helmet there and I would carry
it off for him right and I'm sitting
there and I look across over there and
there Sherman looking at the magazine
and I'm looking at Sherman and then
Sherman picks his head up and he looks
over me
he smiles and just the words came out
his mouth
Oh Broadway Broadway Joe and man from
that time on it was cool it was nice he
co-signed it he allowed the rest of the
team off for him to say that yeah that
caught on that was cool yeah really
interesting it's super interesting for
me to look from afar somebody who thinks
about attention and marketing that whole
process jumping - did you have any idea
that the pantyhose commercial was gonna
be that big you know what this is the
guy over here that handled that
situation that's the walsh and i would
tell me about that we were together in
Tuscaloosa Alabama New Jersey guy
Hungarian Irish ears Hungarian
Pennsylvania and you know we're in
Tuscaloosa Alabama that's where our
friendship started when Jimmy came to
New York and passed the bar exam up here
in the attorney we started working
together and Jimmy causes Joe I have an
interesting proposal here I've got a
story believe me real quick and I'll
just show you at that point were you
getting tons of different things and you
were betting them and this one just
caught your eye did the day when they
pitched it to you say look Joe's legs
are banged up like like was it very easy
to see the cleverness of it or did that
develop later as an idea yes yes
yeah I mean Joe like like honestly like
Joe wearing panty what year was it 71
do you remember somebody okay like that
is a risky move
yeah you know what no man I liked it I
sold a humor in it first of all was a
job and it was a good job and it was
with a good company when you belong by
the way I've seen the commercial billion
top like were you blown away how good
your legs actually looked and of the
commercial for anybody who's not
watching maybe we'll edited on the blog
like it's a pan up of legs and it's
coming kind of up from the toes from
left to right and like it's nice looking
legs like and then all of a sudden it's
jump like like that did that like like
were you even stunned when you first saw
it like man these things really work
wait a minute if beauty miss that can
make these legs look beautiful still god
I think what they can do for yours one
taste by hand know what I got it got it
got it
I don't remember that by the way let's
look my commentating you know you make
that transition you did that for a while
now you know you play soccer you play
football even sometimes basketball and
you tape your ankles and knees you have
to shave your legs make sense so my legs
were already shaved talk to me about
sports casting you enjoyed it was that I
was it or was it not was it like it was
a nice thing to do like where did that
sit I wasn't educated enough to know
that the controversy the critiquing
needed to be a harsher I was more of a
protective player yeah still being a
football locker room kind of teammate
yeah and I wasn't really keen on it I
understand talk to me about you know I
think a lot of people when they think
about back to nerding out a little bit a
lot of people talk about Don Maynard I
wanna talk about George Sauer
what kind of teammate was he you know
just talk to me about it well they're
both from Texas says you know and you
mentioned Dawn Maynard first and I want
to go back to their Kansas City chief
game we didn't have dawn in that game he
was hurt we had another Texan bake
turner but they also had a cornerback
that was really good as in the Hall of
Fame and so they shut down our game
pretty good that day George Sauer
I have often said Don Maynard is in the
Hall of Fame he was the lightning strike
the knockout punch every team had to
respect his tricky speed man he was
while I was he was terrific the guy I
liked working best with was George tire
George Sauer and I were together Hart
was he great at route running he was
wonderful he was gonna be yes yes we
would work after practice man and as
rookies together and we developed the
timing that was just a wonderful and and
some of the guys the veterans would talk
about even the coaches Don's lack of
discipline and route running will excuse
me he knew how to get open he might have
rounded some routes off personally than
breaking him sharply or whatever he's a
hall-of-famer yes you know he was a man
George Sauer you could always count on
George
I mean being their precise man and he
had hands that I don't remember him
dropping anything and the Super Bowl and
in the championship game there was a
play that George caught a quick out got
hit and fumbled the ball today they
wouldn't call it a fumble they'd call it
incomplete pass it was that fast Lennie
Niles hit him George was wonderful Joe
what about now fandom wise like how much
do you watch Bama or the Jets or anybody
else for that matter
i watch Bama and I watch the Jets weekly
yeah in this day and age you could see
they retired well we took some time off
or how did that how did your fandom post
career develop did you take some time
off after you retired because you just
needed to and that point of your life or
has literally from the day you stopped
playing you Saturday and Sunday you
watch I did take some time away
from football I'm a Gemini there's a
side of me really you know and I believe
in their scanning and I wanted out to
change your pace I wanted experiment I
wanted to learn from these other
opportunities that I did have acting yes
exactly I was some lessons I some acting
that studied acting I studied voice and
I did some other things with theatre as
well as motion pictures but never had
the real passion to do it they were nice
jobs they were good jobs but there's a
side of this Gemini that I need downtime
it's for your health you know I can't I
won't have worked that way spending
hours and then life evolved into having
a family and I enjoy spending time with
the family and also that was cool even
football we've talked about coaching
those coaches work so hard so hard you
gotta have the passion to do it the
passion what you're doing are you go
you've got that passion man you know
that's right so when I got out of
football I wanted to break I wanted to
get away and Jimmy continued to guide me
in directions that we kept growing and
then you kind of got the bug back a
little bit again to start just watching
on Saturdays and so that's how you know
you know what please NFL ticket came
into play you could watch your pro team
so what you were getting I was in
Florida at the time I think so you're
able to start watching we started out
with classic Sports Network yes was
bored that I was on with Ernie Banks and
Wilt Chamberlain and Larry Bird badal
Greenberg Stephen greenberg and Brian
bird all started that bryant god bless
him yes last week and classic Sports
Network was wonderful you know later
when we know what classic Sports Network
was wonderful it allowed a generation my
generation to really get a sense of some
of the icons of sports I mean it was a
really thoughtful product yes I really
enjoyed a lot of I couldn't agree more
nostalgia plays yes nostalgia please
all sports you know not just good balls
as a Jets fan what has been the most
heartbreaking loss for you as a fan not
as a player I'm not my heart breaking
gang I'm not I don't get hard roasting
over sports you know I yeah well they're
more important thing I met you very
briefly because we were both walking on
the field for the Pittsburgh game the
Doug Bryan game when he missed two field
goals okay within the minute that was a
heartbreaker but I weirdly there's this
there's a secret you know Joe Mike my
ambition in life is to buy the New York
Jets that is 100% what I spend my time
on and there is a secret part of me that
wonders if I actually want to be that
person that brings back the championship
so I'm a huge fan i watch every play i
watch every game three years ago my
brother and I went to all 16 games on
the road it's a big passion of mine but
like there was something we ran a
Steelers game where I wasn't a zip set
as the rest of the crew and we drove
back from Pittsburgh and that was the
first time I said do I actually want
this team to win a Super Bowl or do I
want to buy this team and win a Super
Bowl like that was the first time I
actually asked it so you don't get what
how do you feel now you see oh I will
say this you know outside of Penningtons
like first kind of like 80 before he got
hurt that first season when he had that
incredible run you know and as much as I
was excited about Favre but I knew was
later in his career and the team that
that Favre team late in that season
before he got hurt was probably when
they beat the Titans who were undefeated
at the time in week 11 that was maybe
one of the few times I was like maybe
this is the team but out this darn old
kid and I've gotten to know him because
my brother and I started this sports
agency we recruited him we were in his
living room in California trying to
convince him to go with our agency he
didn't go with us but we struck such a
friendship and I'm the last thing I said
to his mother when we were pitching him
was I said mrs. Donald if I had the
option if God was listening to me right
now
and your son would sign with us and go
number one overall to Cleveland or not
go with us and go three to the Jets
I would pick not go with us and three of
the Jets oh man so I'm exactly I mean
this is no question it's such a data
it's a quarterback
League and I do think it takes this and
this and all these intangibles I think
one of the things that's I often times
when I get into a nerdy discussion about
your career I you already brought up a
couple times here today which is why I'm
smiling inside the great great
misunderstanding the number one thing I
think you're most underrated for was
what you did inside the locker room in
your teammates when who you wore in the
outside world without having the ability
to have the humility and to have to
understand the weight you were carrying
in the outside world inside the locker
room that is absolutely your legacy as a
leader in my opinion that's why that's
why you are who you are I think Sam has
that not that he has the same level of
like macro fame but if you do not know
how to work a locker room as a
quarterback and what you have to do off
the field if you're not doing I mean
this kids studying film 24/7 I think we
have a shot with this one a you know I
agree of course Gary I watched him in
college to it as see and he looked like
he had the physical tools and all that
but during the course of the season last
year hearing his coaches especially his
teammates Josh me talked about him and
how they talked about him that left a
better impression even you know I'm
getting to meet him and just visiting
briefly a few times with him really
respect him I like his size that he's
bigger than I then I thought he was and
I can't complain but you know it's a
team game it is the team game yeah team
game who's the most underrated teammate
you ever played with tight end guard
somebody you know obviously there's the
names that we all know but a little bit
left field anybody stand out as like wow
like you know I wish more people realize
you know cuz what's amazing about sports
and it's the same as running a company
it's subtle and tangibles that are very
hard to see you know whether it's
picking somebody up on the bench
whether it's reinforcing something
whether it's keeping somebody in line
who is starting to be a cancer is there
anybody who stands out that even the
hardest korjev fans or you know may not
know I I don't know about the hardest
core jet fans may not
because there's one guy in our offensive
line who took a beating every week our
Center John Schmidt I mean this was at a
time that it wasn't a head slap and
forget about it it wasn't his laughing
man these cats were gonna hit I was
watching in here I was watching Mean Joe
greens this weekend NFL life with my son
Xander did I introduce you to like I'm
trying to educate him on the game
looking at those crazy what they were
doing unbelievable was crazy and then
the linemen had to block with their
hands in here they couldn't even reach
out and you know just take it away from
the offensive linemen and to this day
your games mostly are one in the pits
you know you gotta have the guys up
front on both sides of the bar you to by
putting your phone numbers when take a
couple calls and wrap it up so what's
really interesting about how much did
you love playing in Shea before we get
cuz Shea's got this aura I didn't get to
you know go to any games there because
they moved the giant Stadium at that
point was that there was there was there
was a something about it well yeah it
was in New York for one thing I mean I'm
not putting Jersey they know at all
understand it was also time Porter's but
this was our team out here in Queens you
know right there in the Highlander and
also we got to practice later in
September because the Mets were there
and we shared it with men so we got to
know Tom and the guys you know whatever
yeah but also we got the practice at
Rikers Island Rikers Island as you know
is a prison yeah and that's the most
memorable place every practice tell me
about being in New York during that time
you guys win the Mets win which was
improbable the Knicks win a year later
did you have a relationship with Walt
Clyde Frazier
oh nice relationship we didn't hang okay
oh he was working you just the two of
you are legendary men off the field in
New York City and I secretly have always
I'm so glad I just got to ask you that
cuz if you left that ass I would've been
upset I was like oh man I wonder if the
two of them ever hit the town together
that must have been insanity so you had
respect for each other beginning hello I
was pulling for him well it's a school
magazine x-games
I don't know I was out of town during
that time but I tell you what Roz your
bear I was just gonna ask you was the
man that swears he was the suave and he
was the coolest no games did you do that
when the season was over I usually left
town first of all if you're in New York
186 days a year you are resident and not
that I kept up with nothing I kept up
with it much but we you know much better
outside that's amazing I love that and
having play you were that thoughtful
about it back like you were real
purposeful that makes sense I guess I
only learned no yes sir but I knew I
loved Florida because of being there is
a sophomore in college to play a bowl
game against Oklahoma playing Texas over
Super Bowl a silly and yeah okay yeah so
I knew I loved Florida I loved the
weather down there I got to where I
needed blue skies so you're off season
was Florida Bama a little Pennsylvania
or now Pennsylvania my mother and family
are still my mother's past but my
family's still back there they're
survivors but I became a resident of
Florida in 1970 in 1970 well I know
Connecticut I don't know but did you say
this hello no way how's it going guys
it's going well chase how are you do it
well you got a question yeah so my
question for you is this Joe is there
any is there any similarities between
being a football quarterback and being
an entrepreneur
in question what do you think Joe I know
more about football than I do being an
entrepreneur and entrepreneurialship but
I think management is important of
whatever you're doing and communicating
with the personnel you're working with
yeah there are similarities in life in
general
Joe you also played in the Euro where
you were correct me here you were
calling the place at the line right yeah
we had the Liberty to do that that's
right and take that Liberty a lot and
they still do have the liver I know I
know we complete a New York like
depending on who your coach is of course
I mean I saw field Sims and then Bill
Belichick go at it over there on the
side and I knew our Sims knew what he
was doing out there but you know what if
the play doesn't work and you're
accountable you got to have a reason
coach Ewbank when I was a rookie told us
you know a quarterback if I send in a
player you run what I stand in unless
you have a better play I want to hear
the reason you got to have a reason to
change the play so I did enjoy being
able to when we won the championship
game basically calling 80 plus percent
of our plays at the line of scrimmage a
whole lot of running
well yeah offensive line and meadow know
I never saw anybody play a game like
Matt Snell I mean he not only ran that
ball God knows 20-plus times or whatever
gained so many yards caught passes but
covered on kickoffs too ran down the
field on kickoffs man you know it was a
different era chase thanks for calling
brother thank so much guys you got it
what did you do the day after the Super
Bowl oh did you guys party hard that
night or were you like kind of like what
like happened didn't party hard and ice
a girlfriend with Don and you know truly
I mean I don't even know at this point
it's been talked about so much so many
like I can understand how a kid like
manipulate in one's brain but if you can
for a second try do you think you
understood the magnitude of that win to
me I understood it only as far as a goal
the world
pionship that's what it says on that
ring the world the champion yeah it
wasn't called the Super Bowl at the time
and I've said this again if you're in
Little League make tin every level you
go you want to be the best actually that
part of the team John this is a question
you were already kind of known known but
like did your life actually completely
change after that game though like that
when you were at an airport or at a
diner no matter where you were no like
in the in the country did you just
completely see a big shift yeah
absolutely I went out to San Francisco
after that game I was going on a USO
tour to the hospitals in the Far East
and there was a group of people when I
got to the airport in San Francisco
holding up signs and all that Broadway
Joe congratulations but so you know yeah
it shocked me I'm in San Francisco yeah
that was the the first thing I remember
about really being recognized for that
game did you ever have a conversation
about the game with Unitas I know he
didn't start that game we got to visited
many charity events and golf outings and
you know late night just the two of us
sitting and drinking a little bit
afterwards that we never discussed the
game no no yeah no I get it I get it
this course it at all and Johnny's
myself that see that's the other thing
before that game in in Fort Lauderdale
their defensive tackle Lou Michaels and
Dan Sullivan their offensive guard and
Jim Hudson and I are safety had dinner
together get out of here I knew Lou
Michaels cuz he and my brother Frank
were Kentucky together I love it and so
I got to meet Lou when they came home
from college I was maybe 13 14 at the
time and so we decided to have dinner
and we're sitting at the bar waiting for
a table and Lou and I you know and Jim
yeah Dan we have a drink or two for some
reason I guess the only was a defensive
lineman for some reason Lou turn to me
so you know what yo we're gonna kick
your ass
I said whoa no
man come on I said what and besides what
do you know about it you just the kicker
you got a jaw went straight boy he got
uptight he started to move and but that
time a guy came over with a tuxedo as
the tables ready guys so we got along
the rest of the night all right but
there was some chop-busting obviously
Johnny didn't start the game
did you is hurt that's what I wonder
this Larry I know that when he came in
because he was this legend that I'm sure
you and I know that you looked up to was
there a part of you saying don't do it
just don't I could see myself standing
there in the sidelines right now
I never asked the good Lord to help us
when I didn't really we always prayed
for health and we always prayed to stay
healthy not have injuries but not to
help us win the game when Johnny came
out there I looked up the clock and I
looked up to God and I said please God
let that clock but Johnny wasn't himself
no I told you before I said you just the
kicker to Lou I said Lou
Johnny's hurt he can't throw the ball
across the street yeah and besides that
what do you know just the Kerry cordis I
think Curtis was calling us and then
we're gonna move on and that's the first
guy I thought that we said courtesy to
smart what a gentle
great Curtis yes it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and you're on with the legend Joe Namath
oh holy crap
hey Gary buddy what are you doing good
my question is this in regards to you
know transitioning from professional
sports at your time to afterwards what
do you think the major difference is now
when transitioning from a pro athlete to
whatever because I feel like there's a
lot of issues going on in regards to
finances you know what Curtis this day
and age there's no excuse the the player
didn't want to listen they're taught
maybe not from home but from their high
school coaches from their college
coaches their mentors they're taught
better than ever before to prepare for
the time after your sports playing days
are over
so if you know it's bad luck or they
want decent listeners the players today
are prepared better for everything
outside of football plus the nutrition
they have the training they have because
of the the game's growth and people
looking back and saying how can we do
this better yeah
there shouldn't be an excuse but you
know some guys just yeah I mean it's you
know don't understand what were you
following the little I'm gonna wrap up
with a little more Jets nerdom Ward
Association were you following during
Kenny O'Brien's years yes as a player I
think Kenny was glad he had Wesley
Walker and Kenny was an ace yeah he was
a heck of a passageway that's a blind
situation was real difficult well that's
where it starts you and offensively and
I've said this many times the first
Manning to be in the Pro Football Hall
of Fame wouldn't be Payton and it may
not be a liar if he gets their dad
Archie Archie never had a team to play
with hundred percent he played with the
New Orleans Saints yep not
I used to put bags over their heads fans
did so Archie was a great quarterback
but didn't have the team Dan Marino he's
in the Hall of Fame but didn't have a
team to win to get over the hump to win
a championship Dan lead a team yeah give
him San Francisco's team our team yes so
you know Lady Luck plays a role what
about that defensive line that sac
exchange the clecos the salams the gas
nose what did you think about as Marty
Lyons - yeah absolutely Coleco you
talking about a guy that should be in
the Hall of Fame in my opinion three
different positions you're right and now
how can that be done how can he not be
in the Hall of Fame I question that but
he's in my Hall of Fame and everybody
anybody that's ever played against Joe
Klecko will back that up show the book
what uh you know there's been couple
books with you there's the documentary
was unbelievable I watched that opening
night and then many times over is there
a story out there that even at this
point do you think about I always wonder
about this cuz there's I think all of us
as humans I share a lot about my life
and I document I do a lot of stuff but I
always wonder about the stories that
haven't been told or the underrated
stories at this point your life is there
any turn that has stone that hasn't been
turned is there anything they like your
acting career is there anything that you
know you ever think about stuff that you
haven't talked about yet that you say
well I ever talk about that because we
all go you know and hold a couple things
that we never share but are things that
you've been thinking about sharing that
maybe you haven't shared in the past no
no you know what I have shared a lot and
I haven't ducked things I've you know
starting at home stuff starts at home
and you take the responsibility for your
acts and all and you try to make
improvements on it but some things you
know you may just not write being said
if what's it gonna do is it gonna harm
somebody is it gonna hurt somebody here
or whatever is it gonna be positive this
book
a really important part of it is
reaching out trying to help underdogs
that feel like they're underdogs you
know I keep saying if you have a passion
go for it try it don't let anybody tell
you you cannot do something if you have
a problem with substance whether it be
drinking drugs whatever reach out for
help I went left but when I was married
my former wife asked me to quit drinking
in 1986
okay and I stopped for 13 and a half
years all right yep then I found the
reason to go back and drink I drank for
a few more years and the Suzy Kolber
incident changed my life
she helped I called her the next day
when I found out what I had done that
night I called her in fact Jimmy called
me and told me about it the next day I
didn't know understand so I called her
and I apologized to her and she was so
supportive she inspired me more than I
was inspired at the time but I knew I
let a lot of people down including my
family and friends but you know I needed
help I needed help so I went and got
help I went to a facility I got help I
got a education I like to call it I
wanted to understand why this was
happening when I was in retrospect you
know it just became a way of life it was
bald and and I I got education at a
professional facility then I started
going to AAA and still run across people
and still do see people come over to me
and they kind of whisper Joe I'm a
friend to Bill's well you don't have to
whisper okay so am i yeah grew up in a
in an era where there was a stigma
around that and anytime we as a culture
can eliminate stigma whether it's
alcoholism right now I think the stigma
of the next half-decade next excuse me
two three decades hopefully as mental
health issues that we can start
eliminating this stigma to allow people
to feel comfortable because other
people's judgment dictates a lot of our
behavior yes yes and and the day
you know I mean if you can be addiction
to the good Lord and love okay but the
many of the times we talk addiction it's
negative you know it's right and so if
you if you get caught in that kind of a
thought if you think you've got a
problem you probably do and you need to
reach out because there are people that
want to help you Joe it's been an honor
to have you thank you yeah one of the
fun things on this show is the person
gets the guest gets to ask the question
of the day so I want you to I'm gonna
give you a few seconds here to think
you've got thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands over to the next
month and we're gonna watch this what
question do you want to ask the masses
what do you want them to think about
what kind of question Wow big issue
right now with what I've been wrestling
with is trying to understand this
abortion issue interesting and you know
I believe in God I believe in religion I
also believe in the right for a lady at
a time to have a choice on what's going
on how we gonna get that straightened
out started in Alabama - how are we
gonna get this straight now it's a
powerful question Jim thanks for being
on the show all right Thank You gay you
got it you keep asking questions we'll
keep answering them
on this episode my favorite human being
in the world stops by